einstein ist zurück das glaubt
jedenfalls die harvard university
ok wiedergeburt ist jetzt nicht das was
vermutet wird aber es gibt eine
wissenschaftlerin und sie ist noch sehr
jungen einem physiker sind die alle in
den schatten stellt und sie bricht jetzt
schon alle rekorde sammler cottbus
passiert ski baute mit 14 jahren ein
flugzeug und zwar einen richtigen zu
ihrem vater so diese mmc in rekordzeit
physik mit bestnote markiert ihren
doktor an der harvard university und
dass unser ganz besonderen
rahmenbedingungen klicks um seite
fiction über die neue einstein herzlich
willkommen
ja ich will sowieso davon überzeugt dass
frauen in der wissenschaft systematisch
unterdrückt wurden sie wurden tot
geschwiegen ignoriert an den rand
gedrängt wer weiß heute schon dass vilja
-7 fleming das system zur stern
katalogisierung entwickelt hatte
das aus dem wasserstoff anteil in ihrem
spektrum basierte und damit 10.000
sterne katalogisierte wie es die
entdeckerin von hunderten sternen gab
nehmen und norway oder marie curie eine
der wenigen frauen die mit einem
nobelpreis ausgezeichnet wurde
tschuldigung mit 2 1 sie bekam 1903 den
nobelpreis für physik und 911 den
nobelpreis für chemie
wie war der erste mensch der 2 nur
weltreise erhalten hat damals gab es
übrigens an deutschen universitäten so
insgesamt rund 1500 studenten kurz zuvor
dürften die noch gar nicht studieren
heutzutage sind knapp 50 prozent der
studienanfänger studentinnen und auch
beim abschluss ist der anteil bei knapp
50 prozent aber dann treten wieder
verhältnisse aus dem vorigen jahrhundert
1 44% der doktorarbeiten sind von frauen
39 prozent der wissenschaftlichen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter sind
frauen 24 prozent wird immer weniger
derjenigen in die habilitieren also eine
arbeit um professoren zu werden
schreiben den frauen 18 prozent der
stellen für professorinnen und
professoren sind dann von frauen gesetzt
und bei den topf stellen sind immer noch
mal weniger 13,6 prozent also auch heute
noch werden frauen im
wissenschaftsbetrieb systematisch
benachteiligt gefühlt zum beispiel eine
studie zu mündlichen prüfungen im fach
jura
während abiturientinnen im schnitt
genauso wie abiturienten also beim
abschneiden ist das bei der jura
abschlussprüfung anders und zwar
seltsamerweise vor allem in der
mündlichen prüfung forscher 2014 die
abschlussprüfung ab oberlandesgericht
hamm ausgewertet in dieser studie hatten
die frauen sogar die besseren abi noten
schnitten aber vor allem in den
mündlichen prüfungen die nicht wie die
klausuren analysiert waren schlechter ab
an der harvard business school werden
die mündlichen prüfungen übrigens
verschriftlicht und anonymisiert seitdem
schneiden baut studentin gleich gut ab
die studenten seltsam dann ist da die
meldung über die einstein an wichtig
sabina gonzalez pastörs die scheint
die wissenschaftliche turbo karriere
hinzulegen west note 5 am massachusetts
institute of technology in physik
studium für das sie nur drei jahre
gebraucht hat und jetzt macht sie ihren
doktor und zwar nicht an irgendeiner uni
sondern an der harvard university ihre
fachgebiete wie übrigens auch meine
lieblingsthemen schwarze löcher raumzeit
gravitation und hier speziell die
krankenkasse station sieht also offenbar
überall dahin wo es wirklich interessant
ist und auch wirklich komplizierte dabei
hatte sie vorher mit den gleichen
problemen zu kämpfen wie wohl jede frau
sie wurde unterschätzt und am mpi und in
harvard abgelehnt da war sie allerdings
noch nicht volljährig aber genau dieser
ehrgeiz scheint sie auszuzeichnen
deswegen wird sie jetzt auch ziemlich
umworben die nasa würde sie gerne
einstellen und auch amazon gründer jeff
bezos würde sie gerne bei seinen
raumfahrtprojekte dabei haben aber es
scheint so dass sie eher in der
theoretischen physik forschen wird und
dort astrophysik ihr fach wird wird oder
eben quantenphysik oder oder oder
vielleicht wird sie sogar auf mehreren
fachgebieten aktiv da ist ja nicht
ausgeschlossen einer neuen einstein ist
dazu zu kommen
viele erwarten von ihr nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als dass die bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse gewinnen wird kaspersky
lässt das allerdings kein zitat ein
theoretiker der sagt er wird in einem
bereich bahnbrechende erkenntnisse
gewinnen garantiert dadurch eigentlich
dass genau das nicht eintreffen wird
da hat sie wahrscheinlich recht was
wirklich zählt ist die leidenschaft und
das interesse und nicht dass sie
irgendwie herausragendes zu leisten das
kommt dann sowieso von selbst wenn wir
dann tatsächlich bahnbrechendes
entdecken sollte oder spektakuläre
theorien aufstellt erfordert das
natürlich hier der bedarf nicht mehr
drücken wir hier ein aber aufs auge
unvergesslich dem auf die glocke denn
nur dann werdet ihr auch über neue
videos informiert und bekommt
nachrichten wie clixoom hat
einschneidende lautet ja ihr geht es
weiter mit unseren besten videos in
einer playlist vollkommen neu
zusammengestellt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran